?
>> JUST HORRIFYING.
FOR ALL INVOLVED.
IVAN WATSON JOINING US LIVE
FROM SEOUL, MANY THANKS FOR
THAT UPDATE.
>> INVESTIGATIONS ARE UNDERWAY
AFTER A DEADLY BRIDGE COLLAPSE
IN INDIA ON SUNDAY, RESCUE
CREWS ASSISTED BY THE INDIAN
MILITARY ARE SCRAMBLING TO FIND
SURVIVORS AND AT LEAST 134
PEOPLE WERE KILLED.
INCLUDING CHILDREN WHEN THE
FOOTBRIDGE GATEWAY, PLEDGING
DOZENS INTO THE RIVER BELOW.
AND OFFICIALS SAY THAT THE 19TH
BRIDGE HAD RECENTLY BEEN
RENOVATED.
CNN'S KRISTIE LU STOUT IS
FOLLOWING THE STORY AND SHE
JOINS US LIVE FROM HONG KONG.
SO CHRISTY, WHAT IS THE LATEST
ON THIS TRAGIC BRIDGE COLLAPSE
IN INDIA?
>> ROSEMARY, SINCE WE LAST
SPOKE.
THE DEATH TOLL IN INDIA
CONTINUES TO CLIMB, THIS IT
RECENTLY RENOVATED BRIDGE, THE
SUSPENSION, BRIDGE COLLAPSED ON
SUNDAY IN THE WESTERN INDIAN
CITY OF GOOD DROP, AT LEAST 134
PEOPLE WERE KILLED AS A RESULT.
INCLUDING CHILDREN.
AND THE WHOLE MINISTER OF GOOD
DROUGHT STATES, HELD A PRESS
CONFERENCE EARLIER TODAY INTO
THE GOVERNMENT THERE HAD
LAUNCHED A CRIMINAL COMPLAINT
AGAINST THE AGENCY RESPONSIBLE
FOR THE MAINTENANCE OF THE
BRIDGE.
ALSO ADDING THAT THE
INVESTIGATION WITH THE SPECIAL
TEAM IS NOW FULLY UNDERWAY,
AUTHORITIES EARLIER SAID THAT
THEY BELIEVE 200 PEOPLE WERE ON
THIS BRIDGE AT THE TIME THAT IT
COLLAPSED, THAT TOOK PLACE
SUNDAY EVENING.
6-30 PM, LOCAL TIME.
AND THE VIDEO THAT WE ARE ABOUT
TO SHARE WITH YOU IS VERY
DISTURBING AND DISTRESSING TO
WATCH, THIS IS VIDEO THAT HAS
BEEN CIRCULATING ON SOCIAL
MEDIA.
AND IN, IT YOU SEE THE
IMMEDIATE AFTERMATH OF THE
BRIDGE COLLAPSE.
YOU SEE PEOPLE CLINGING ON TO
THE CABLES, AND THE TWISTED
WRECKAGE OF THE BRIDGE.
SOME TRYING TO SCRAMBLE TO
SAFER GROUND, OTHERS FALLING
INTO THE RIVERS WATER BELOW TO
THE SHORE.
MANY SADLY DID NOT MAKE IT AND
TRAGICALLY, MANY OF THE VICTIMS
ARE CHILDREN.
HERE IS AN EYEWITNESS.
>> [INTERPRETER]
MANY CHILDREN WERE ENJOYING
HOLIDAYS VIRTUALLY, AND ALL OF
THEM FELL ON TOP OF ONE
ANOTHER.
THE BRIDGE COLLAPSE IN DUE TO
OVERLOADING.
>> AND HAPPENING THIS DAY ON
MONDAY, SEARCH AND RECOVERY
TEAMS ARE COMBING THE RIVER TO
LOOK FOR ANY TRACES OF THE
MISSING.
THIS BRIDGE WAS A POPULAR
TOURIST ATTRACTION, IT WAS
BUILT IN THE 18 HUNDREDS DURING
BRITISH RULE.
IT HAD BEEN RECENTLY RENOVATED,
WAS CLOSE FOR A FEW MONTHS, AND
REOPENED LAST WEEK.
PRIME MINISTER MOODY IS
CURRENTLY IN GOOD DRAFT.
THAT IS HIS HOME STATE.
AND HE HAS EXPRESSED HIS QUOTE,
DEEP SADNESS, IN THE WAKE OF
THIS TRAGEDY.
BACK TO YOU.
>> SHOCK